today guys I'm gonna find out what the
public really think about Andrew Tate
some people think he's a misogynist he's
a sexist others think he's the top G and
the absolute man let's find out what the
public really think my name is Leia
heilpan don't forget to hit the like
button and the Subscribe button so you
never miss a video Andrew Tate
interesting guy has some things that I
don't agree with what don't you agree
with I think some of the things that he
says especially about financial side
you're broke two men or woman I'm like
man that's like pushing it can you give
me an example of something that he says
about women that you disagree with the
fact that
let me think Andrew also says that a
woman is low value if she slept with
loads of men so what do you think about
a woman who's had let's say slept with
50 men my body count probably 10 times
that so like I can't really shame nobody
for what they did in the past so would
you marry a woman that's been with a
hundred men I mean now if I know that I
just oh that's a different story
probably well you do know I'm telling
you she's been with 100 men would you
take her no so you do agree with Andrew
yeah you agree as well yeah
so what do you think about Andrew Tate I
think his views are horrendous but I
don't hate him because hate would
require me to give him energy and I'm
not giving them any of my energy your
time I'm glad that he's off social media
and that he's been banned on most
platforms what are one of the views that
you disagree with just like what he
thinks about women that women are his
property and that like women have to do
whatever their husband says like that's
a big no no for me bro what are you
talking about man he literally looks
like a human penis head he has sexually
assaulted so many women there's so many
complaints about him he goes on he
treats women like their property like
what is your value four-time kickboxing
world champion trillionaire humble tell
me what is it that he said about women
that you disagree with
like you should shoot them like
materials were like I'm just like no man
they're people just like us I don't
think it's true there's a man that gives
Millions to charity he's opened dog
shelters and he says that women are the
most precious thing in the world what do
you think about someone like that I
think they have some value in their life
um that's a very good thing I love
animals anyway especially dogs so that's
awesome do you know who Andrew Tate is
I've heard of them but I don't really
know too much about them okay that's
what we're talking about oh well Andrew
Tate you're dope you know who Andre
tatus yes of course and do you like him
no why
um I don't know he says some pretty
harsh things about women what did he say
um I don't know just things are like um
I don't know I don't know specifics I
can't get into the specifics I don't
know why so how can you not like someone
if you can't give me an example that's a
good question
I'm gonna describe somebody to you he
gives a lot of money to charity he says
women are the most precious thing in the
world and he helps lift men out of
depression what do you think about
someone like this I think that is
somebody that we have to give all credit
to I think in my own personal opinion so
this person is Andrew Tate by the way do
you know who that is I'm familiar with
Andrew take yeah I think he's a great
person personally I I didn't know you
were talking about Andrew take what's
your take on Andrew Tate hate them why
do you hate him I just think he's
misogynistic can you define misogyny for
me
um it's practically like not thinking
that like you're better than women but
thinking that there's like
like in like in general like uh there's
a man that gives a lot of money to
charity he says that women are the most
precious thing in the world and he wants
to help men fight depression what do you
think of someone like this there are
really good things I mean someone that's
helping men getting out of depression
and someone that's giving money to
charity so I think it's good this man by
the way is called Andrew Tate a lot of
people don't like him why they don't
like him I think it's really cool what
he's doing I agree it's your take on
Andrew take there's some things that he
says that I agree with and there's a lot
of out-of-pocket things he says that I
don't what do you agree with yes the men
should be the providers I don't mind
that at all of course every lady likes
to be taken care of he is the protector
he's the provider you know things like
little things like that six and a half
hours later because he's so picky about
like having someone with no body count
and like just being super selective so
would you marry a woman that slept with
over 50 men I wouldn't personally
because I've been married before and
divorced so I wouldn't so that's what
Andrew Tay says he says body count
matters you have to be selective I think
so I think
so we agree with Andrew I would say I
agree with him on majority of it so how
do you know that he has actually
sexually assaulted women there have just
been enough complaints that it's kind of
like if you hear like a CMP there's
probably horses this is Haram this isn't
prehistoric times you're not gonna knock
me over the head with a club and drag me
back to your cave and you think Andrew
would knock someone over the head with a
club I think he would definitely try he
helps men fight depression that's
actually one of his biggest viewed
YouTube videos what are your thoughts on
those how does he do that I've never
I've never seen that uh that video he
just talks about leaving the Matrix
taking personal responsibility going to
the gym just self-improvement what do
you think about that from what it sounds
like he's perhaps telling men that they
have to fight through their feelings and
I feel like that's not the way to
approach things I think men are supposed
to be vulnerable and should be
vulnerable and can be emotional and any
kind of like toxic masculinity where
you're telling men to fight through all
of that is not okay in my book can you
define toxic masculinity yeah toxic
masculinity
um I think you know impacts all genders
and to me it's basically you know
um this belief that uh one of the things
he says is that he prefers a woman who
has a low body count what do you think
about that that's his opinion I don't
really care this is him so would you
marry a woman that's been with 100 men
yeah
what about a woman that's been with 500
men
same thing
a woman is a man's property what do you
think about that you know everybody have
their own opinion about what other other
people say I think when he says that I
think he has a reason why he's saying
that I mean women have their own opinion
not to like him from what you described
I think he's a great man um you know
individual and I think people need to
respect him he says that he prefers
women who are younger and have low body
counts in terms of how many men that
they've slept with what's your take
every normal guy would want that is that
what you want that's what I want
obviously you don't want to have you
don't want to deal with a woman that has
been messing around a lot of people okay
so if you're marrying a man and he's
paying for everything right would you
like to sort of be his property and that
he'll look after you the same way he
looks after let's say like his car his
house I don't need somebody to like
constantly be like looking after me I
just need some like if he's my husband
like he should love me but he shouldn't
be like feeling like the need to look
after me I'm an independent person
what if there's somebody dangerous on
the streets that's gonna come attack you
I own pepper spray okay but he's got a
knife
and I could get a taser you don't want a
man to protect you in the jungle out
there okay let's say I have like a
scrawny husband like how much is he
really gonna be able to protect me well
you're gonna pick a scrawny man no I'm
not exactly why aren't you gonna pick a
scrawny man because that's just not my
preference but like that is some
people's preference it's not some
people's preference all women want big
men that's not true I've met some
interesting women do you want to be a
CEO and a boss [ __ ] yes why
because I want to be able to make my own
money and provide for myself Quran he
once said that women are the most
precious thing on the planet what's your
take I don't know I don't like that I
feel like yeah we're strong we're
precious and we're strong so I feel like
him saying we're precious is kind of
like dimming down our strength so I
didn't really like the he thinks like a
man should provide for a woman what do
you think about that I think women can
also provide for ourselves you know what
a man that can provide for you I want to
provide for me and then he can spoil me
I don't think it's true you're actually
the first woman today that's told me
that she wants a protector and a
provider tell me why you like this I
mean
I'm not you know big enough to fight
somebody out in the dangerous streets
like I've lived here my whole life and
there's a lot of creepos that come out
and harass you and say things to you
that just are not kind so you know
having somebody there to protect you and
know that you know if something does
happen everything will be okay that was
a long day we spoke to a lot of
different people and they have a lot of
different things to say I think my
conclusion is people don't really like
him and also they don't know why they
don't like him like I said I've met the
guy I don't think he's misogynistic I
think he's a very nice man and I think
what he's doing for society especially
for men is so important guys don't
forget please hit the like button and
the Subscribe Button as there's more
videos coming just like this